SPEAKER 1: Hi, and welcome
to this OpenCue tutorial.
Today I'm going to walk
through submitting a render
job to OpenCue and go over some
of the functionality in the Cue
GUI monitoring application.
Here we are inside
Maya, and we're all
ready to kick off a render of
our robot dance party scene.
We've set up our
Maya Render settings.
This render is
going to use V-Ray.
And now we'll jump
over to our render cam,
just to make sure
everything looks good.
Once we're ready
to submit the job,
we can switch to
the OpenCue shelf
and click on the
Submit or Shelf button.
This will launch the
OpenCue submission form
as a Maya plugin.
This UI can also be launched
as a standalone application
from the command line.
The first thing that we're
going to do is enter a job name.
And then we'll give
it a shot name.
And then we'll enter a layer
name-- in this case, lighting.
Then we'll select
our render cam.
If we don't select one,
it'll just use the camera
from our render settings.
And then we'll input the
frame spec we want to render.
So for more information
about this frame spec syntax,
we can hit the
question mark icon.
This will give some
description and examples
about the frame spec syntax.
Next we'll set up the job type.
Job types define
what parameters are
exposed in the submission UI.
We'll leave it set
to Maya in this case.
And then Services--
services help
us define default resource
requirements and tags
for this job.
We'll submit this
to the Maya service,
and we'll leave the min core
requirements set to zero.
This allows CuBot to send
the job to any size machine.
And since this is just
a single layer job,
we'll leave the
dependency set to none.
But perhaps you wanted
a more complex job.
Maybe you wanted to
kick off a Nuke render
to be dependent on this.
You could hit the plus button
and configure a new Nuke
layer that would be dependent
on our lighting layer.
For this demo,
though, we're just
going to do the simple,
single layer Maya render.
And at this point we can
double check our parameters.
If everything looks good, we'll
go ahead and click Submit.
And we'll get a
little window pop up
that says the job's been
submitted to OpenCue.
And at this point, we
can jump over to Cue GUI.
So there you can
see our robot's job
has popped up in
the Job View there.
And this is Cue GUI,
the main interface
for monitoring the state
of everything in OpenCue.
It's a [INAUDIBLE]
application that's built
on multiple dockable
widgets, allowing the user
to be able to customize the
interface to their liking.
And at the top we
have the Job View,
and down below is the
Monitor Host view.
So we'll switch over to
the Job Details view,
And then we'll double
click on our job.
And this will show us
the hierarchy of the job.
Going from top to bottom,
first we have a job.
A job is a container
for a single submission.
Then we have a layer.
You can think of a
layer as a command
with a frame range to run,
and at the bottom is a frame.
A frame is an individual
instance of that command,
with a single frame or chunk
to be executed by a host.
So next we're going
to walk through some
of the other
interfaces in Cue GUI.
You can open up new panels
through the Views plug-in menu.
We'll start with opening
the Shows interface.
This view will display
a list of shows
known by OpenCue and some high
level stats about that show--
things like the total number
of running frames and pending
frames.
From there, we'll open
up the Allocations view.
Allocations are a grouping
mechanism for hosts.
Generally an allocation
is defined by the facility
that the host lives in-- in
this case, local or cloud.
And then there
will also be a tag.
These tags will be applied to
any host in that allocation
by default. You can
see the number of cores
in each allocation here.
Next we'll take a look at
the Subscriptions view.
Subscriptions exist for a
show, so we'll select the show
that we're interested
in, and it'll
list the available
allocations for that show.
This, then, defines what host
can run jobs for a given show.
All the allocations show the
size, usage, and burst amount.
You can edit these
parameters by right-clicking
on an allocation.
You can also edit the show
settings from this view
by clicking on the Show
Properties button, where
you can set the
core requirements
and do things like enabling
or disabling booking.
We'll go ahead and close
the Subscription View,
and we'll walk through the
Monitor Host View next.
We'll go ahead and
turn on Refresh
with no filter to populate
the full list of hosts.
And this will tell us
all sorts of information
about the RQD hosts
active in OpenCue.
We can open up the
Attributes view
to explore this information
a little closer.
You can see things
here like System Stats
and the allocations and
tags for this host--
in this case, Cloud General,
and on this other host,
Local Unassigned.
And if you notice, only
one of these machines
is running right now.
That's because our dance
party job was submitted
to the local facility.
So only the host with
Local General allocation
is eligible to run that job.
The one with Cloud
Unassigned cannot.
If you need to do anything
like modify the host,
you can right click on the
host and do things like change
the allocation, add
tags, delete the host,
lock or unlock the host,
and also leave comments.
That about covers the basics
of the Host Monitor view.
And next we'll look at some more
of the job configuration views.
We'll start off with
the Services view.
Services are a way
of classifying a job
and defining some default
requirements for that job.
Here we have a list
of services defined
by different applications.
And you can see there are
default system requirements
and tags that get applied
to jobs in that service.
These parameters are
defaults, though,
and they can be overridden
at job submission time
or once the job
has hit the queue.
So we'll jump back to
the Job Details View
to take a look at how
services are applied to a job.
So we'll select our
job and right click
on the layer we're
interested in.
If we open up the
Properties dialog,
we'll see something very
similar to the Services View.
This information,
by default, is all
populated from the service that
was selected at job submission
time.
Like I previously mentioned,
that's just the default,
though, and it can be changed
on a layer by layer basis
if needed.
So we'll go ahead
and close that.
And it looks like our frames
are starting to finish up.
There's still a number
of frames running,
but these green
ones are finished.
So we'll take a look
at the Log View.
If you select the log
and open up the Log View,
you'll see the render
log for that frame.
In this case, it's a V-Ray
log that includes all
of the output from that render.
There's a handy search
feature down here
that allows us to quickly search
for specific text in the log.
You can also open up the log by
double clicking on the frame.
In this case, it will open
in [? MacVim ?] for me.
You can edit this by specifying
your editor in an environment
variable.
That about covers the basics
of the OpenCue GUI interface.
Thanks for watching.